fun group welcome to detention Spencer
Bethany fridge Martha you're all here
for a reason you know what it is you
should be thinking about who you are and
who you want to be fortunately you'll
have plenty of time to figure that out
while you're cleaning out the basement
that sucks
yeah it's mystery is this Jumanji
a game for those who seek to find a way
to leave their world behind where those
avatar names so you pick a character and
then you're that person in the game so
I'm gonna pick I don't think it matters
how much should be played
[Music]
hey where the rest of me my god
bridge young fridge who are you it's me
Spencer who is she
think we got sucked into the game and
we've all become the avatars we chose so
that means I'm Bethany Bethany Bethany
[Applause]
I'm an overweight middle-aged man
welcome to Jumanji
[Music]
Wow
have to warn you think I'm a very strong
puncher
[Music]
don't cry don't cry don't cry it's gonna
be okay alright alright
I can't help
you